bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce 7 décembre
les dirigeants russe rejette toutes les
critiques et tous les avertissements des
occidentaux à propos de la tchétchénie
et maintiennent leur ultimatum des
vacations de grozny avant le 11 décembre
deuxième partie de notre enquête en
colombie premier producteur et
exportateur mondial de cocaïne mais ceux
qui la cultivent n'ont pas d'autres
alternatives pour vivre
nouvel aspect de la gestion contestable
de la mnef la carte jeune 1,2194 aurait
entraîné la perte de plus de 12 millions
de francs le nom de michèle alliot marie
apparaît dans cet épisode
journée nationale de l'hypertension 4
millions et demi de français prennent
des médicaments pour leur tension mais
ils doivent aussi être très vigilant
dans le suivi du traitement
cinéma avec le film dans la peau de john
malkovich où l'on entre dans la tête de
l'acteur john malkovich
à pied en charrette en camion en voiture
les tchétchènes habitant la capitale
grozny fuit actuellement la région
depuis que les rues sont avertis que
ceux qui resteront dans cette ville au
delà du 11 décembre seront considérés
comme des terroristes ou des bandits
inacceptable disent les pays occidentaux
ainsi jacques chirac les dirigeants
britanniques le secrétaire général de
l'otan ou encore le président de l'ol
c'est eux l'organisation pour la
sécurité et la coopération en europe au
fce dont fait partie la rue
inacceptables ces pressions occidentales
c'est ce que répond moscou qui affirme
toujours que la guerre en tchétchénie
est une affaire intérieure commenté
gilles rabin avec franck brisset l'armée
russe préparent l'assaut de grozny elle
le fait savoir elle a autorisé le
tournage de ces images sur la ligne de
front pour montrer la plus grande
concentration de chars et de blindés vu
depuis trois ans depuis la fin de la
première guerre de tchétchénie qui
s'était soldé par une défaite humiliante
pour la russie les canons tirent à tirs
tendus ordre est donné de passer coûte
que coûte et pour ce faire l'armée
détruits tout ce qui pourrait présenter
une résistance ou une simple menace la
ligne de front et à deux kilomètres
seulement de grozny ceux qui vivent
encore doivent quitter la ville
encerclée avant samedi
la date de cet ultimatum n'a pas été
choisi par hasard samedi le 11 décembre
c'était en 94 le premier jour de la
première guerre la guerre perdue dans
grozny survivent près de quarante mille
personnes des vieillards des femmes et
des enfants qui n'ont pas eu les moyens
de quitter la ville l'armée russe a
prévenu après le 11 décembre ils seront
tous considérés comme des combattants
pour prendre la ville l'état major est
prêt à utiliser des armes nouvelles qui
tue et brûlent tout ce qui vit y compris
sous terre les armes dites binaire
ils ont déjà utilisé dans les zones de
montagne
les zones ce peuple est là où il y avait
nécessité technique et donc fait fit
binaire les ont utilisés à are gone
c'est très probable qu'ils les utilisent
aussi à grozny
bref c'est un massacre qui s'annonce
massacre de combattants tchétchènes et
de civils confondus
les américains avaient déjà utilisé de
telles armes pendant la guerre du golfe
sur l'armée ennemie pas sur une ville
et pour bien appuyer le mécontentement
des occidentaux à l'égard de la russie
c'est le président des etats-unis
lui-même qui s'est exprimé après le team
hatton du commandant militaire russe
écouter bill clinton
les habitants de tchétchénie sont dans
une position terrible
assailli par les groupes terroristes
d'un côté et par l'offensive russe de
l'eau jobs
la russie va payer le prix fort elle
s'enfonce de plus en plus dans un
bourbier qui va accentuer les
extrémismes et affaiblir sa propre
position dans le monde
mais la maison blanche exclu ce soir une
réduction de l'assistance américaine à
moscou en faisant valoir que l'essentiel
de cette aide à l'ère des programmes
renforçant la sécurité nationale des
nations unies alors les pressions les
menaces de sanctions économiques ne font
pas peur au premier ministre vladimir
poutine gilles rabin il est bien décidé
à aller jusqu'au bout oui tout à fait la
bibliothèque est le président le kremlin
sont déterminés à aller jusqu'au bout
quelles que soient les mises en garde ou
les menaces de sanctions des pays
occidentaux vous savez claude il faut
bien comprendre que la prise de grozny
constituerait une revanche non seulement
sur une guerre perdue il ya trois ans
mais aussi sur plus de dix années de
frustrations et de recul constant de la
russie or il se trouve le doublement
inespéré cette année du prix du pétrole
permet à la russie grands pays
producteurs de se passer pour un temps
de l'argent des occidentaux le temps
d'une double campagne électorale celle
des législatives de la semaine prochaine
et celle des présidentielles le vrai
rendez-vous de jeu à 2000 alors vous
comprenez que rien ne changera la
détermination du kremlin de prendre
grozny quel que soit peut-être qu'on
soit le prix diplomatique par tous les
moyens et quelles qu'en soient aussi le
coût en vies humaines merci gilles en
serbie l'union européenne vient
d'apporter une aide concrète à deux
villes en opposition régime de slobodan
milosevic des camions citernes remplis
de fioul sont arrivés à nice pour
ravitailler une population qui
actuellement beaucoup de mal à se
chauffer en ce début d'hiver reportage
alexandre irish avec les commentaires de
gérard griesbeck après 13 jours et 13 me
d'attentes les chauffeurs peuvent enfin
se détendre car pendant tout ce temps
les autorités de belgrade ont joué avec
les nerfs des occidentaux un jour les
camions sont bloqués parce qu'il manque
des papiers un autre jour parce que la
taille des engins n'est pas aux normes
mais tout cela est déjà oublié le fuel
est arrivé c'est l'essentiel
c'est bien c'est très bien on va avoir
du chauffage et tout ce qui va avec
et si l'on demande pourquoi le fuel
n'est pas arrivé plus tôt
cet accueil de notre connerie
quelle connerie de notre gouvernement
pourquoi ils ont bloqué les camions
c'est une vieille habitude communiste de
dire que seul le maître peut sauver son
peuple la ville de niche et géré par
l'opposition c'est la raison pour
laquelle les occidentaux lui ont apporté
leur soutien concret il s'agit de punir
le régime de milosevic et non le peuple
serbe
nationaux ça n'est pas seulement un peu
plus de chauffage pour les serbes c'est
le symbole du retour de la serbie en
quatorze camions de fioul ne feront pas
tomber le président milosevic
mais les occidentaux comptent bien
poursuivre leur aide à l'opposition
en allemagne le parti social démocrate
allemand a réélu aujourd'hui à sa tête
le chancelier gerhard schröder malgré
toutes les critiques qui émanent
notamment de la gauche du spd présents à
ce congrès le premier ministre français
lionel jospin a qualifié de relations
d'exception l'amitié franco allemande
mais au cours de ce congrès monsieur
coderre a eu l'occasion de s'en prendre
surtout à son prédécesseur helmut kohl
qui est actuellement au centre d'un
scandale de financement occulte de la
cdu ou l'union chrétienne démocrate
helmut kohl a reconnu avoir utilisé de
1982 à 1998 divers comptes bancaires
secrets pour recevoir des fonds destinés
à son parti la cdu ou une enquête est en
cours mais le prestige d'helmut kohl et
tata et au fur et à mesure que les
détails abondent comme cette histoire
née de la vente d'une raffinerie c'est
halloween la correspondance olivier
lerner et yogan dombrowski le plus gros
investissement français de
l'après-guerre en allemagne c'est loana
la raffinerie achetée par le groupe elf
a coûté et 20 milliards de francs
certains vie au début que le prix a été
trois fois supérieur à ce qu'il devrait
être et qu'une partie de l'argent a été
versé en commissions qui auraient servi
à alimenter les caisses de monsieur cool
pour sa dernière campagne électorale
parce que je veux dire l'affirmation
j'ai jamais entendu dire personne fin le
prix trois fois ce qu'ils auraient dû
être non non on fait raffinerie le
montant prévu c'est bien le montant que
coûte une raffinerie aussi complexe pour
l'oin à 250 millions de francs de
commissions auraient été versés dans les
caisses du parti d'helmut kohl la cdo il
a d'abord nié en bloc les accusations
puis il a admis que des erreurs pouvant
prises et l'illégalité avaient été
commises sous sa direction enfin il à
avouer l'inavouable gestion séparée des
comptes traitement confidentiel de
certaines affaires autrement dit qu'est
ce soir et podevin c'était pour servir
mon parti at il dit en guise de défense
une explication un peu courte qui ne
satisfait personne qui alimentait les
caisses de la cdo qui a encaissé
l'argent si elles nouent de cole se
garde bien de tout dire d'autres le font
pour lui l'ancien expert-comptable de
l'axé des roues par exemple a décrit
devant les juges le système colle une
commission parlementaire se penche sur
la vente d'airbus et d'hélicoptères au
canada et à la thaïlande la vente de
blindés à l'arabie saoudite autant de
cas de corruption présumée des millions
d'autres marques auraient été versés à
zurich dans cette banque l'image du
grand européen s'effondre helmut kohl
incarné à lui tout seul une classe
politique allemande est propre c'est la
fin d'un an
et y moralité responsabilité guerre
achat d'un employé aujourd'hui ces trois
mots devant les membres de son parti
réunis en congrès et pour la première
fois le champ seulement accusé son
prédécesseur helmut kohl d'avoir failli
à son devoir
en colombie comme chaque jour depuis
plus de 30 ans compte les morts et les
blessés victimes d'attentats victime de
la guérilla hier c'était à medellin avec
l'explosion d'une voiture placé non loin
de cette grande société de production
d'électricité une des caméras de
sécurité cette entreprise un film et
l'explosion explosion qui a fait un mort
depuis hier et demain encore dans cette
édition de 20h avec nos envoyés spéciaux
thierry thuillier bruno girodon nous
vous proposons une enquête en trois
parties sur la situation de violence en
colombie nous avons évoqué hier soir les
négociations de paix qui se tiennent
dans une zone sous contrôle de la
guérilla ce soir voici un reportage
réalisé au coeur même de la production
de la cocaïne la colombie est le premier
pays producteur et exportateur mondial
de cocaïne chaque année 250 tonnes de
coca et 6 tonne d'héroïne sont fabriqués
les gains estimés aussi entre 200 et 600
millions de dollars mais celui qui
cultive la coca n'a pas vraiment d'autre
choix pour survivre
comme le rapportent nos envoyés spéciaux
l'endroit est si coupé du monde que
cette en bateau qu'il faut rallier
cartagena d'accueillir
trois bonnes heures pour découvrir le
sud de la colombie
aux confins de la forêt amazonienne
il n'y a rien d'autre que le village de
cartagena dette chahira et d'immenses
espaces quasi désert
pourtant guérilla armée et trafiquants
s'en disputent le contrôle pour
comprendre il faut encore s'enfoncer à
l'intérieur des terres d'eau numéro est
notre guide il ya cinq ans victime de la
crise du café il a quitté son ancienne
propriété pour s'installer ici la nature
est hostile sauf pour une plante la coca
c'est l'objet de toutes les convoitises
la cultiver est interdite mais dans la
région les chants sont nombreux et avec
un peu de temps un étranger il ya accès
sans être inquiété d'ailleurs et miro en
parle tranquillement
je sais que j'ai plus ou moins cinq ou
six hectares
tous les deux mois j'en tire court
disons 10 mille francs avec un hectare
et demi
beaucoup plus qu'avec une autre culture
et il me re doit faire vivre sa famille
il n'a donc pas le choix la coca
voyez dès la première année la coca vous
rapporte quelques petits billets tandis
qu'il faut quatre années au moins pour
commencer à produire des fruits par
exemple
pour inciter les paysans à abandonner la
coca il faudrait une aide économique de
l'état mais la voie choisie par le
gouvernement est différent régulièrement
des avions dispersent des pesticides sur
les champs de coca pour les détruit sans
résultat deux fois ils sont passés chez
emi row 2 x black hawk a repoussé pas
les arbres ni les autres cultures
dans son laboratoire et miro se charge
lui-même de faire la première
transformation d'un coq
les substances que nous utilisons c'est
l'essence d'abord et puis du ciment 20
ans c'est la première étape d'un
processus qui aboutit à la production de
cocaïne
de l'essence sur l'extrait de la farine
ont la seiche et en avant à des
commerçants on les connaît pas et eux
ils ont un traitement un traitement pour
l'exportation
pas d'états d'âme chez ea niro de toute
façon la guérilla comme le gouvernement
le conforte dans son choix le marché de
la cocaïne c'est le poumon économique il
finance même la guerre civile
la guérilla prélève des impôts sur les
intermédiaires des acheteurs de coca
la seule façon d'en finir avec la coca
c'est avec la main d'oeuvre
l'arrachage des plants nous les paysans
ont pu le faire
si le gouvernement du z a changé les
cultures illicites et à trouver des
alternatives
alors nous le ferons
en attendant donne miro a une famille à
nourrir alors il continue et tous les
producteurs font comme lui
en quelques années le nombre d'hectares
de coca cultivée a été multiplié par
deux
et demain troisième partie de notre
enquête en colombie réalisé par thierry
thulliez bruno girodon nous verrons une
réponse très militaire et par certains
côté pittoresque à ce trafic de drogue
l'équitation judiciaire de la lainière
de roubaix c'est la décision du tribunal
de commerce de cette ville la fin de
cette entreprise c'est aussi la fin d'un
symbole celui de la prospérité de
l'industrie textile de la région nord la
fermeture de l'usiné les 250 personnes
au chômage déçue mais pas surprise car
depuis dix ans les plans sociaux se sont
succédé avec à chaque fois des promesses
et des espérances vite démentie au début
du siècle la lainière employés 7000
personnes à la fin de cette année on
fermera les portes définitivement
reportage à de mourgues et patrick leurs
stops à lignières
tu es mon travail c'était ma vie tout
mon mari aussi on était à deux dans la
lumière et comme beaucoup d'entre nous
d'ailleurs c'est notre
visible et continuer notre vie
entre brigitte et la lainière 25 ans de
vie commune en quelques mots le tribunal
de commerce a scellé le destin de lusine
de roubaix le tribunal après en avoir
délibéré prononcé la liquidation
judiciaire de laysan nouvelle filature
lainière de roubaix
man liquidation judiciaire fermeture du
site 250 ouvriers de plus au chômage
j'ai qu'un salaire de 50 ans
la lumière présentée après la guerre
comme un modèle de réussite
un modèle qui reçut même en 57 et la
visite de la reine d'angleterre
l'entreprise compte alors 7000 salariés
fabrique 90 millions de pelote de laine
par an c'est le règne du pull over fait
maison et des chaussettes qui gratouille
mêlant pire se lézarde crise du textile
guerre de succession les plans de
restructuration se succèdent la
concurrence étrangère porte un coup
fatal
ce métier est extrêmement concurrencé
par les importations asiatiques par des
importations turques
pour lui imaginer que quand nous vendons
nous la france 28 airbus à la chine la
chine va bien payé avec quelque chose et
elle paiera les textiles saper la
troisième fois je suis licencié ça va
faire la troisième fois je vais devoir
me remettre à zéro et recommencer à 44
ans qu'est ce que je vais faire manquer
ce que je vais trouver le coeur n'y est
plus lederrey gîte est quand même
retourné à l' usine terminer les
dernières commandes et partir la tête
haute elle le sait elle n'a qu'une
faible chance de retrouver du travail
dans une file qui compte déjà près de 30
% de chômeurs
lac ans et est aujourd'hui coupé du
continent termes de transport aérien
aucune desserte or figari n'était
assurée à la suite d'une grève du
personnel de la compagnie corse
méditerranée ccm outre ce conflit les
postiers corses n'ont toujours pas
repris le travail bloquant une bonne
partie de l'activité économique corses
commentaires emilie lançons
ajaccio calvi bastia dans les trois
principaux aéroports corses les vols
sont annulés les mécaniciens de la
compagnie corse méditerranée rejoint cet
après-midi par l'ensemble du personnel
se sont mis en grève motif la ccn risque
de perdre son monopole sur les liaisons
avec le sud de la france une autre
compagnie air littoral jugé plus
compétitive a remporté l'appel d'offres
mais cet après midi le coup de théâtre
est venu des politiques après trois
heures de négociations avec
l'intersyndicale le président de
l'assemblée territoriale corse fait
machine arrière
je réfléchirai donner son avis sur
les prothèses
l'annulation la procédure d'offre
les élus de l'assemblée territoriale se
prononceront probablement jeudi sur
cette annulation les grévistes eux
décident en ce moment même de la
poursuite au nom du mouvement
quant au conflit à la poste et d'ajaccio
il dure depuis deux mois et semble même
se durcir ce matin plusieurs dizaines de
postiers ont attaqué les bureaux de la
direction départementale de corse du sud
les grévistes ne se contente pas des 47
créations de postes premier à l'occasion
du passage aux 35 heures un million de
lettres et de colis sont toujours
bloqués en politique à paris pas
question d'attendre mars 2001 et la
campagne électorale municipale pour
faire acte de candidature pour
multiplier les initiatives payante
évidemment on prête des électeurs le
maire rpr jean tiberi déploie depuis
plusieurs semaines une intense activité
en annonçant une série de projets pour
la capitale soucieux sans doute de
rejeter en arrière-plan toutes les
rumeurs sur les affaires ce qui
n'empêche pas les socialistes depuis
leur victoire dans le 20e arrondissement
de rêver eu un succès total reportage
avis inverse jacques gérard et marcel
martin en général la victoire d'un
adversaire politique est une mauvaise
nouvelle mais chez jean tiberi cela ne
se voit pas le maire de paris garde le
sourire quoi qu'il arrive même lorsque
les socialistes affirme que l'hôtel de
ville est désormais à leur portée il
rêve ni se trompent je pense au
contraire que nous pouvons que nous
devons garder la majorité aux prochaines
élections municipales c'est ma
conviction est d'ailleurs les bilans le
résultat du travail que nous menons
ensemble dans le cadre de la majorité
municipale sera un élément à mon avis
déterminant avec vous mais je l'espère
bien
jean tiberi confirme donc qu'il sera
candidat le décor des élections
municipales et presque planté car depuis
dimanche et leur victoire dans le 20e
arrondissement
les socialistes dévoilent leurs
ambitions françois hollande lui-même a
donné le poids
comment le long chemin qui devront lui
non pas simplement
mais le problème aujourd'hui à gauche
c'est de départager les candidats
dimanche les possibles prétendants
étaient réunis dans la même salle jack
lang qui n'a pourtant qu'un mandat
parisien ne voulait pas rater cette
soirée peut-être déjà pour tester sa
popularité à quelques mètres de là
bertrand delanoë marquer son territoire
le patron des socialistes à l'hôtel de
ville lui affiche clairement la couleur
je suis un des candidats possibles
j'aime paris j'y suis élu depuis
longtemps et j'ai beaucoup d'ambitions
pour cette ville et pour gagner le ps
table aujourd'hui sur la mauvaise image
de l'actuel maire et conseiller de jean
tiberi le savent ils préparent déjà la
riposte jean tiberi d'après l'ennui les
emmerdes ils sont qu'elle comptait
monsieur strauss kahn ce bar cambadélis
ce bar le guen se barre ils ont tous un
peu la trouille alors ils disent qu'ils
peuvent gagner doit mais à mon avis sont
très mal partis vous savez tous les
coups seront donc permis dans la course
à la mairie de paris à gauche comme à
droite les états majors on ont déjà fait
la priorité de ces prochains mois autre
affaire celle de la mnef la mutuelle
nationale étudiante de france olivier
spithakis l'ancien dirigeant est
toujours emprisonné et parmi les
investigations en cours la police et les
juges pourrait bien s'intéresser à la
carte jaune elle fut inventée en 1994
par le gouvernement balladur qui lança
un appel d'offres la nef emporte à cet
appel d'offres et la gestion de cette
opération avec l'espoir officiel de
vendre 2 millions de cartes mais en cinq
ans trois cent mille seulement seront
placés la perte financière serait estimé
entre 12 et 30 millions de francs et
c'est la ministre de la jeunesse et des
sports de l'époque michèle alliot-marie
qui lance à l'appel d'offres
explications avec l'en quête de julien
commères et olivier caroff
s'ils en sont arrivés là c'est qu'avec
la carte jeunes ils ont pu bénéficier de
réductions pour louer une voiture
acheter un appareil photo trouver un
hôtel et même s'offrir le voyage
c'est la plus grosse dégringolade
financière que la nef est connue lors
des années 90 la carte jeune a coûté
cher à la mutuelle étudiante
terre cette carte à puce devait offrir
de nombreux services d assurance des
réductions l'idée avait été lancée fin
94 par le gouvernement d'edouard
balladur un appel d'offre fut
officiellement organisée le vainqueur la
mnef le père dans un groupe spécialisé
dans la genèse à partir de l'attribution
de l'appel d'offres en fait nous avons
plus de relation donc plus de rendez
vous donc c'est pour ça que nous envoyer
les courriers pour demander de
l'information
la simple nous n'avons pas une réponse
écrite à st près de pons orale que nous
avons eue c'est pas faire de vagues
qu'est-ce qu'on vous êtes dit quand on
vous a dit faut pas faire de vagues
pas faire de vagues ça veut dire
effectivement c'est qu'il y en a
certainement à faire les vagues c'est la
cour des comptes qui valait provoqué en
novembre 81,18 elle conclut à un manque
de transparence de la part du
gouvernement le ministère vise et celui
de la jeunesse et des sports était à
l'époque dirigée par michèle alliot
marie
je suppose que votre question en rapport
avec l'élection à la présidence du
repère pour tous les cas je ne peux
malheureusement pas vous dire grand
chose étant donné que la carte jeune a
été gérée par un organisme complètement
extérieur au ministère
pourtant dans cette lettre aux perdants
de l'appel d'offres est signée de la
main du ministre michèle alliot-marie
écrit après avoir entendu l'avis de la
commission chargée d'examiner les offres
j'ai décidé de ne pas retenir votre
proposition
l'actuel président de la mnef était à
l'époque un leader des mouvements
étudiants pour lui pas de doute
le ministre s'est occupé de près du
dossier le gouvernement balladur a
besoin de redorer un peu son blason
auprès de la jeunesse et
c'est à cette époque michèle
alliot-marie spithakis passé un accord
on débouche sur la création de la carte
jeune olivier spithakis l'ancien
directeur général de la mnef aujourd'hui
en détention provisoire avait veillé à
rester présentable pour un gouvernement
de droite extrait du rapport
parlementaire sur la mnef cette liste en
94 aux anciens trotskistes viennent se
joindre des membres de l'udf et le rpr
françois baroin conçu comme une réponse
aux manifestations de mars 94 la carte
jeune a été largement boudée par les
étudiants à quoi cette filiale de la
mnef at elle vraiment servi la mutuelle
a fait ses comptes 12 à 30 millions de
francs de pertes elle s'apprête à
dissoudre la société anonyme carte jeune
le président du crédit lyonnais perdu
son procès contre bernard tapie monsieur
peyrelevade poursuivi monsieur tapie en
diffamation pour avoir affirmé que le
crédit lyonnais l'avait spolié dans
l'affairé adidas le tribunal a estimé
que bernard tapie était de bonne foi et
a donc débouté le président du crédit
lyonnais à rennes aujourd'hui le père de
la jeune britannique caroline dickinson
violer tuer en 1996 à pleine fougères
est venue une nouvelle fois lancé un
appel à témoins alors que les enquêteurs
étudierait actuellement une nouvelle
piste jugée intéressante monsieur
dickinson s'est adressé directement à
tous les témoins potentiels
s'il vous plaît rien qu'un instant
mettez vous à ma place à la place de la
famille de caroline essayez d'imaginer
de souffrance mais souvenez-vous aussi
comment caroline est morte et si vous
même vous êtes parents si vous êtes un
père ou une mère pensez à vos propres
enfants le cri d'un père devant micros
et caméras une nouvelle fois aujourd'hui
john dickinson est venu à rennes
rencontré le juge van ruymbeke le père
de caroline lance un appel à témoin
alors que se profile une nouvelle piste
celle d'un ouvrier qui auraient
travaillé à l'époque du meurtre sur un
chantier des environs de pleine fougères
selon le tuyau des enquêteurs l'homme
serait soupçonné par ses collègues il y
aurait des collègues de travail de
l'ouvrier meurtrier qui saurait et qui
jusqu'à présent ne veulent pas parler
est la raison de la présence de john
dickinson aujourd'hui c'est précisément
qu'invité ces gens-là ses collègues de
travail là et bien à faire taire leurs
scrupules car rien ne permet pour
l'instant de recouper ce mystérieux
tuyaux de la cellule caroline des
chantiers en cours en juillet 96 il y en
avait plusieurs centaines dans la région
les gendarmes n'ont donc d'autre choix
que de les vérifier un parent et de
compter sur la bonne volonté des témoins
les gens qui ont gardé le silence ne
peuvent plus se taire est allé trop loin
s'ils doivent pas aller maintenant car
il n'est jamais trop tard garantiront
leur anonymat et nous les protégeons ils
peuvent nous aider ils le feront je
l'espère
depuis deux ans tout a été mis en oeuvre
pour retrouver le meurtrier de caroline
dickinson sans résultat pour l'instant
même si aujourd'hui les pistes semblent
bien convergé dans la même direction
reportage à rennes d'olivier cieux
gabriel camilla à paris dans le 19ème
arrondissement non loin de pantin une
jeune fille de 19 ans qui se
prostituaient a été assassiné crime
hélas presque banale où l'on retrouve
tous les éléments de la misère avec
l'histoire d'une femme venus de bulgarie
est prise dans un réseau de prostitution
mais ce crime a provoqué l'indignation
de voisins qui ont voulu en début
d'après-midi en déposant une gerbe sur
les lieux de l'assassinât que leur
réaction ne soit pas isolée reportage et
réclamations et philippe jasmin à cet
endroit un mot vient à l'esprit sordide
la rue de la clôture sous le
périphérique est parfaitement sordide
des prostituées qui travaillent ne sont
pas du haut de gamme bien qu'elle soit
très jeune le jour elles sont quatre les
albanaise encore toute fraîche qui
rencontre le client directement dans sa
voiture ou au choix derrière la
palissade parmi les ordures
c'est à cet endroit qu'un dimanche soir
à l'heure du film une de leurs collègues
a été massacrée de 23 coups de couteau
par un client pervers ou par un
souteneur
c'est arrivé depuis longtemps
c'est banal à meurtres de prostituées
mais derrière son bureau tout proche
cette jeune mère de famille en a été
révoltée elle l'a écrit à un journal
pour qu'au moins dit elle la fin
misérable de sa jeune voisine ne passe
pas inaperçu ces filles ont pas de vie
elles ont une vie sordide une fille
atroce et on voit pas pourquoi cette
noire passe passerait sous silence
on a envie de dire qu'on ne veut plus
être un témoin de ça qu'on peut pas
l'accepter si on accepte on consent si
on consomme bien compris avec ses
collègues de travail la jeune mère de
famille a acheté une gerbe de fleurs
déposées aujourd'hui sur les lieux du
meurtre d associations d aide aux
prostituées sont venus mais pas les
quatre jeunes albanaise qui ont continué
à travailler juste à côté comme les
autres jours
quand on lit
en france un produit elle répond d'un
air las
d'habitude c'est la vie elle était
bulgare elle avait 19 ans et se faisait
appeler jerry les riverains de cette rue
sordide voulait qu'au moins une fois on
parle d'elle c'est fait
un arrêté ministériel vient de
reconnaître l'état de catastrophe
naturelle pour 63 nouvelles communes des
pyrénées orientales touchées par les
intempéries récentes précédemment 29
communes de ce même département avaient
déjà été visée par un autre art est
aujourd'hui et demain deux journées
nationales de l'hypertension pour mieux
faire comprendre les enjeux du
traitement et du dépistage de cette
maladie dont souffriraient plus de 7
millions de français 4 million et demi
d'entre eux prennent des médicaments
mais la moitié de ceux-ci le font de
façon plutôt irrégulière compte tenu des
contraintes ces journées doivent
mobiliser l'attention des balades qui
pourrait par exemple suivre les
précautions de ce septuagénaire modèle
rencontrées par françoise vallée et
christian odin
claude est hypertendu il l'a découvert
il ya trois ans lors d'un contrôle pour
une opération chirurgicale
depuis il suit un traitement pour
permettre à ces artères de moins
souffrir et chaque jour à la maison
l'autre surveille sa tension
avec ce petit appareil il apprend du
même trois fois de suite puis fait une
moyenne
m'aperçois depuis peu près trois ans que
on est descendu de 16 à 15 en moyenne
est de 15 à 14 donc à partir de là on
est sûr fin qui a rien de particulier
le traitement marche et que le
traitement fonctionne avec ces chiffres
claude trace une courbe qui la portent
régulièrement à son aide aux familles
mais il n'échappe à la prise de tensions
ponctuelles avec l'émotion la pression
monte la comparaison avec ses propres
données montrent bien que les chiffres
c'est peut-être ont peur tout à l'heure
j'ai mesuré votre tension elle était à
16 est en fait cette tension ce n'est
pas votre tension de tous les jours
puisque chez vous dans les conditions de
l'automation vous n'avez que très ému
inutile d'augmenter la dose d'auto
mesure bien confirmer l'efficacité des
traits plus elles permettent aussi de
mobiliser les personnes hypertendues
contre une maladie insidieuse que l'on
ne sait pas guérir le problème de
l'hyper tension sexuelle sans symptômes
et quand les symptômes sont là et bien
il est trop tard le mal est fait il faut
donc prévenir il est indispensable dans
la prise en charge de l'hypertension
artérielle que le couple médecin patient
fonctionne bien des études récentes
montrent qu'un traitement bien adapté et
bien suivi permet de réduire de 50% les
complications cardiovasculaires
demain à toulouse airbus industrie réuni
son conseil de surveillance pour évoquer
un avion hors norme un super jumbo à 3 6
x dont les dimensions et les capacités
mais depuis quelques temps l'imagination
et le talent des ingénieurs à rude
épreuve c'est un projet mais il y a déjà
des images d'anticipation commentaires
patrice pollet
la 3 x c'est l'avion de tous les plus le
plus grand 80 mètres d'envergure le plus
lourd 550 tonnes celui qui emporte le
plus de passagers 700 places sur deux
pots
voici dans la plus grande cabine du
monde la classe économique
et le salon de la classe affaires
l'escalier monumental qui mène à l'étagé
et dans ce cockpit deux équipages se
relaieront aux commandes pour couvrir
des trajets de plus de 14 mille
kilomètres et comme les voyages sont
longs il faudra bien occuper son temps
salle de gymnastique et pourquoi pas
couchettes pour les plus fatigués les
gigantesques train d'atterrissage sont
déjà laissés ils sont dotés
d'amortisseur spéciaux pour éviter que
le choc de l'atterrissage le fasse
exploser le béton nos ingénieurs ont
finalement choisi une disposition de
cinq jambes de train avec un train de
plus de vin rouge il a fallu étudier et
il faut savoir le ranger dans fuselage
et en os voilure mais ce géant va poser
des problèmes
ces turbulences aussi forte qu'il faudra
attendre cinq minutes derrière la 3 x
avant de pouvoir décoller s'il à 3x voie
le jour il faudra aussi refaire
l'infrastructure des aéroports
multiplier les services de douane et de
police agrandir les salles de
récupération des bagages avec la 3 x
c'est la totalité du transport aérien
qu'il va falloir repenser
les sports du football avec le match
retour des 16e de finale de la coupe de
l'uefa en allemagne à brême c'était sur
france 2 le werder de brême battu 3 0
par lyon à l'aller a renversé la
situation en important 4 à 0 sur son
terrain et en + henderson a loupé un but
tout fait à la dernière seconde
commentaires julien est riche on a
priori anderson et l'olympique lyonnais
devait passer une soirée tranquille
victorieux 3-0 à l'issue du match aller
face aux allemands du werder brême la
qualification semblait acquise mais d'un
a priori en football cela ne dure pas
bien longtemps démonstration dès la 17e
minute les allemands ouvrent la marque
mais jusqu'ici tout va bien cela se
complique déjà beaucoup plus lorsque l'
arbitre de la rencontre siffle un
penalty pour les allemands 2 à 0
lacombe s'inquiète et l'ol prend l'eau
de toutes parts les lyonnais qui reste
sur deux échecs consécutifs en
championnat de france sont totalement
inefficaces face à la puissance
allemande un troisième but de bowman et
les lieux proche de la catastrophe la
catastrophe
elle arrive à la 77e minute le quatrième
but allemand de pizzaro anéanti les
espoirs français
jusqu'au bout anderson va essayer
d'inscrire le but salvateur sans succès
neuf fois sur dix un club vainqueur 3 0
au match aller se qualifie le werder
brême pour ce soir qu'un exploit vaut
tous les a priori
les lyonnais eux sont éliminés
voilà et puis c'est déjà l'avant coupe
du monde 2002 qui se disputera en au
japon et en corée du sud l'équipe de
france est automatiquement qualifié pour
la phase finale mais il faut quand même
s'intéresser aux éliminatoires au tirage
au sort effectué aujourd'hui à tokyo en
présence de michel platini pelé
beckenbauer et beaucoup d'autres parmi
les résultats de ce tirage qui
concernait 195 nation un duel entre
l'allemagne et l'angleterre pour les
éliminatoires
du cinéma avec demain la sortie du film
dans la peau de john malkovich un film
américain avec john malkovich où l'on
n'entre dans la peau du comédien de
façon onirique et fantaisiste
présentation nicole cornu langlois un
marionnettiste génial et incompris donc
au chômage se présente pour être archivé
mini du martin kaymer building c'est un
étrange bureau je vais remballer là je
ferme avec lui on entre en douceur dans
le fantastique et l'absurdité paraît
normal il y a une toute petite porte
dans mon bureau maxine c'est un passage
qui conduit tout droit dans john
malkovich tu vois le monde à travers les
yeux de malkovich ensuite au bout de 15
minutes tu t'es éjecté dans un fossé du
nu jazz est à côté du pelage un voyage
interséries brasles impossible à
raconter impossible aussi de savoir ce
qui s'est passé dans la tête des auteurs
pour mener à bien cet ovni
cinématographique et convaincre john
malkovich acteurs énigmatique de jouer
son propre rôle
je pense que le film est sûre la
frustration des gens qui veulent être
quelqu'un d'autre mais pour moi c'est
très peur et pour 13 les gens semblent
vraiment maintenant vivre dans un monde
virtuel
excusez moi monsieur est ce que vous
savez exactement quel genre de services
sont offerts par cette société on
devient john malkovich fourneaux en 15
minutes et c'est de son billet
fasciné par ce jeu de miroirs john
malkovich va au bout de l'expérience et
veut lui aussi rentré dans sa propre
tête
quant à la belle cameron diaz elle s'est
enlaidie prête à tout pour cette
périlleuse aventure
tout avait pris un sens moi je savais
qu'ils étaient tu n'étais pas toi tu
étais malkovich city lui
saisissent a
chuté
si john malkovich
spectateurs soit sur tr je ne voulais
surtout pas qu'ils me reconnaissent
j'étais moi aussi dans la peau de
quelqu'un d'autre elle est vraiment tout
incident à l'opposé de moi
chacun s'est investi totalement perdant
tous ans des conventions pour le film le
plus original et le plus vertigineux de
cette fin de siècle
peau de john malkovich et demain sur les
écrans avant la fin de cette édition je
vous rappelle l'information concernant
la tchétchénie les pressions
occidentales les menaces américaines qui
ne font pas plié moscou qui construit on
utilise opérations militaires et
maintient son ultimatum d'évacuation la
capitale grozny par les civils pour le
11 décembre
dans quelques secondes nathalie rihouet
et la météo ensuite un éléphant ça
trompe énormément d'yves robert puis
mireille dumas qui s'interroge sur les
phénomènes insolites dans la vie à
l'endroit et florence duprat qui
présente le journal de la nuit vers 0 h
45 demain 7h50 gérant morin recevra
nicole péry la secrétaire d'état aux
droits des femmes sur le projet de loi
sur la parité à 13h parité vous
retrouverez carole gaessler et rachid
aaron à demain 20h bonsoir merci
tous